a lawsuit has just been filed against
prince andrew
over allegations of sex abuse let's
speak now to our royal correspondent
rihanna mills who joins me on the phone
and we know this
involves virginia g frey who in a
statement said the lawsuit was brought
under the
child victims act to allege that she was
trafficked
to him and sexually abused by him
that's right anna so in the last half an
hour it's been confirmed by
virginia dufrese lawyer you may have
heard her before called virginia roberts
that was her
her maiden name her lawyer david boyes
has confirmed that they have indeed
filed this lawsuit in federal court
over in america against the duke of
york now in a statement david boyes has
said
in our country no person whether
president or prince
is above the law and no person no matter
how powerless
or vulnerable could be deprived of the
law's protection
over the past five years prince andrew
and his advisors have stonewalled every
attempt to resolve this matter
without litigation it's now long past
the time for him
to be held to account now of course this
is a story that we've talked
a great deal about and it all revolves
around the links between
prince andrew and the convicted
pedophile geoffrey epstein who of course
took his own life last year now of
course at the center of all this
throughout the years that we've
discussed it has been that photograph of
prince andrew
with his arm around virginia roberts now
prince andrew it has to be said has
always denied
meeting her has denied having any sexual
contact with her
however virginia roberts has alleged in
these court submissions that she was
directed by jeffrey epstein who she
worked with
as a masseuse uh that she allegedly
claims that she was forced to have sex
with prince andrew on three occasions
in 2001 in london in new york and the
u.s virgin islands when she was only 17
years old of course that was illegal
over in new york it wasn't of course
illegal over
in london now we're told that this
lawsuit now seeks
unspecified compensation and accuses
prince andrew of sexual assault and
intentional affliction
of emotional distress in the lawsuit
it states that 20 years ago prince
andrew's wealth
power position and connections enabled
him to abuse a frightened
vulnerable child with no one there to
protect her it's long past the time for
him to be held
to account also virginia du frey tonight
has released her own statement in which
she has said
today my attorneys filed litigation
against prince andrew under new york's
child victims act as the complaint lays
out in detail i was trafficked to him
and sexually abused by him i am holding
prince andrew accountable for what he
did to me
the powerful and the rich are not exempt
from being held responsible for their
actions
i hope that other victims will see that
this is possible
not to live in silence and fear but one
can reclaim her life by speaking out
and demanding justice now of course it
is very important to point out this
evening that we have
approached those who represent the duke
of york this evening they are not
commenting however when we look back at
the times that we have reported
uh quite extensively on this case
previously
prince andrew through the palace have
said in statements that it is
emphatically denied
that prince andrew had any form of
sexual contact or relationship with
duffray
the allegations made are false to any
foundation
rhiannon with that breaking news thank
you very much indeed for that so one of
jeffrey epstein's longtime accusers
has sued prince andrew saying that he
sexually assaulted her when she was 17
lawyers as you heard there for virginia
dufrey filing that lawsuit
in manhattan federal court we will
obviously keep an eye on that but uh
as rihannon said there uh the
spokesperson for
prince andrew is suggesting there will
be no comment
tonight after that filing